قوه اسرائيليه خاصه تدخل بزي المدني مخيم
جنين عند السابعه صباحا بعد اكتشاف امرها
وتعرضها لاطلاق النار من مسلحين فلسطينيين
اجتاح الجيش الاسرائيلي المخيم واوقع عددا
من الضحايا بين قتيل وجريح
بعد ساعه على انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
مخيم جنين بقيت دخان المتقاعد من هذا
المنزل شاهد على اربع ساعات من الاشتباكات
والانفجارات التي عمت احياء مخيم جنين
خلال اجتياح الجيش الاسرائيلي للمخيم
ومحاصره المنازل
الاتحاد
الدور وبلغ شو اطلاق انا ارجع على البيت
احتجز في البيت اللي تحت هذا البيت
احتجزوا فيه اصحاب البيت
وقعدوه مسكره علوم البيت وبلشوا من البيت
نفسه يضربوا ونرجع البيت هذا الصواريخ
من سقطوا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي فيما لا
يزال العشرات يتلقون العلاج في المشاكل
الفلسطينيه وصفت جراح اربعه منهم بالحرجه
في الاراضي فلسطينيه في عمليه وصفت
بالاعنه في منذ تولي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده زمام الحكم في اسرائيل ما ينظر
بتصعيد خطير على صعيد الصراع الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه
في المنطقه من مدخل مخيم جنين خالد القاسم
العربيه